21 ci fanno sentire
[Applauso]
scopo
non ci guardate questi personaggi
stranissimi oggi giocheremo al grigio
nuovo gioco si chiama puppet che
sarebbero tipo il burro caldo li pupazzi
di grendi vedete che hanno divertito di
grandi amata di cremi pre sono un mix
tra premi e pighi si disse ti chiamo
subito che mi sono pronti via rocca
allora devo dire che sembrano piuttosto
carini loro come pupazzetti carcereil
occhio rosso niente fa un po paura non
credo proprio che saranno carini aspetta
fra celeranno con quella mazza zona
natura carini dobbiamo trovare il modo
di scappare dalla casa proprio come
ingressi e impieghi quindi iniziamo
subito a cercare le chiavi ci sono vari
i lucchetti prima che arrivino i pupazzi
malefici ma perché arrivano far due
minuti e 25 secondi
non credo che quello sia il tempo totale
in cui dobbiamo scappare
ma i capelli lunghi bagni se il ragazzo
però sta arrivando sta arrivando adesso
sta arrivando
cosi al porpora il fortune che io che io
sono riuscito a scappare ma forse mi ha
visto l'anno scorso qui come ho fatto a
prendere che è stato spesso io
non lo so com'è possibile ma la press ha
preso anche se
è utile per bot ha eliminato tutti
quanti madonna difficilissimo che
vediamo dobbiamo votare il posto allora
casa prigione foresta combina lago
biblioteca ospedale famoso mia fattoria
la gente una grata la pompa giocatore o
bot
facciamo un giocatore che ha visto che è
uno di noi può essere il cattivo se è un
evento con pupazzi 4 ha bisogno di due
anni ecco tu che non troppo negativo i
capelli ma pupazzi ma qui serve matteo
non sapevo di aumentare qua e mi
raccomando ha
cucinato
cibo potrebbero arrivare ancora più buon
basket l'aspetto ha trovato la chiave
più attenti bravo allora va bene fuori
fuori fuori fuori fuori d'opera fuori
c'è un rocchetto blu davvero fuori dalla
casa dei tre tornado
si è fatto uscire aiuto io non ci credo
proprio quando riprendono a chiave
magari aspettare un pochettino
ecco la piccola chiave blues sempre
della mattina ok presa ora stato fuori
dalla finestra senza dei rumori stravede
sprecati calabrò ei manager sbaglio
che cosa devo fare se sono immigrati è
bravissimo non giocatrice ha messo un
ingranaggio trovare l'ingranaggio rosso
scoperto la mischia manomesso con questo
gioco di squadra il muro
di gomma scappassero grevi e pighi è una
fusione un po strano finita e tipo wow
il casco in garage e ti abbiamo
marchionne verde e martello il martello
serviva vicino alla porta ok allora
portiamo il martello prima allora non è
molto lontano da qui allievi martello
dove va utilizzato che qua si suleman
successo a fianco questa fianco forse
l'hanno già utilizzato
io lo hanno già utilizzato prova a
vedere
no capire l'altro questo giocato qui si
può salire su
un'altra
come fatto ma ok votiamo subito allora
non la catano perché votano tutti
non a caso mi piaceva sono il paradiso
[Musica]
è stata scelta la casa ovviamente il
giocatore voglio lino voglio fare
infettati hanno scelto è stato scelto il
giocatore che ti sarà vita non c'è molto
dolci questo caso ci guai a testa i miei
libri eccoci qua temi e nobili subito
identiche rosa pizzo alla tua
trasporto in 7 secondi
tigrotti vidal ernst a cremano bella
divisa in fazioni
ecco sì ciao
ma siamo tutti qui vi stavate aspettando
ho visto che può essere un tabellone con
tutti gli oggetti da prendere quelli che
sono già stati presi
già eliminato qualcuno di certo i netti
quasi mi stava sparato con la pistola
quella che vogliamo vincere noi contro
evitare dobbiamo vincere noi
certo non ci si guarda mani sanità dove
sei
aiuto aiuto aiuto
mi vede mi talento non si fosse chiusa
brunita vita
ma dov'è il look at arancio non è
possibile non c'è nessuna parte schietto
arancione stai cercando non l'ho visto
dalle sue parti voi ne avete visto da
qualche parte vediamo fare e se qualcuno
che urla
no guardo più come si gioca
riteniamo che non si riesca a prenderlo
la pistola c'è qui uno qui assolutamente
non dovete vedere allora la pistola così
possiamo sparare vita felice poi lo devo
di certo la barriera e ora dove siamo
sempre un passaggio segreto davvero ma
cosa c'è qualcuno fuori
non so quale chiede mi serva più di
forse due ma proviamo con questa
qualcuno qui che sta andando
[Musica]
sbagliato
di narnia lo zio ben dietro
perché mi ha fatto finire questa colta
denunce e niente non ha senso o no
sentito un rumore di uno straccio
allevamento preso un altro giocatore
qualcuno ha osato scrivere ai motori
sono ci credo ok qual è la posizione
ma io non sono la usarle per a queste
chiavi se non ci sono i lucchetti
qualcuno ha messo quale botticelle cosa
di legno per patthar bravissimi
il lucchetto
io sono stata io sono mangiati con ciò
che non è andato anch'io peccato che non
lasciava giovanna già dovuto noleggio a
prenderla presto
sto facendo dire la guardia quella
chiave
di mezzo qui c'era anche un altro
giocatore che la stava cercando
levati subito lasciate accorta che ero
lì perché è una pezza la porta quindi se
posso venire a trento attraverso gli
manca sulla chiave bianco
o no tre minuti
ho preferito
stavo per arrivare alla soluzione ci
mancava solo la chiave bianche potevamo
scappare vincere qualcuno sopra ora
siccome sta giocando vitale facciamo da
spettatori si è nascosto da dietro c'è
anche un altro nascosto ma tu non puoi
andare ai miei passaggi perché sei
troppo esitante
anche un altro caduto nella trappola
ma quante giappone
vediamo vediamo quanti giocatori sono
rimaste ancora
[Musica]
che che non so chi sta accadendo molto
bene 2 e 2 questa storia ma questo è
invece sta scappando però adesso
mettiamo una fitta la prossima volta ma
predetto
rimasto solo un giocatore fa sotto anche
se lo prendi avrai vinto la partita
se annunciato poco guarda velocissimo
vediamo se si blocca
perché è arrivato un giocatore
all'improvviso è più di tanto entrano
dei giocatori è molto strano
preso con i tre sono rimasti solo uno
che è venuto bianco con gli occhi di
fuori abbiamo prendendo altre forse
riesco a vincere forse questo piccione
30 secondi dal tas cosi secondo deve
prendere questo giocatore dove si è
nascosto bene
vabbè dai te lo dico anche al di sotto
sta salendo sta salendo eh no e chi pone
hanno sempre rado dire come faccio 15
secondi
o no certo se l'affare
no non ci credo non l'ho preso
pochissimi
ne fai cose perché prima di sembrano che
stiamo fake
ricordatevi che stiamo freschi da
chiamare limitato rese vitale mai caso
stiamo bene stiamo verso il video e ben
estivi 23 febbraio prende vi conviene
giocare bene questa partita
che potevamo fare una società da una
foresta foresta presta ok no perché
votano tutti a casa è perché le case più
bella secondo me
allora facciamo infettati dai piedi per
dirci trattate proviamo con infestati
dai diventiamo tutti hanno scelto
giocatore però bisogno
e magari diventi tu
e film moment slater non ci credono
[Applauso]
alle mie propria vittima sarà vita
allora metti una trappola quando un
giocatore come si fa a mettere le
trappole a con control metterà tutte le
38 a ma nessuno 8 che fiom fisica
proposte primo sappiamo non farti
sparare e linee giocatore
non ci credo season di
a1 o non può trovato miniamo il primo
giocatore perché solo così letto e
micron oggi blu integrata un fam è
lentissimo questo sogno vogliamo pighi
mettiamo qualche trappola ma sai che
io sono un primo giocatore eliminato che
[Musica]
eliminiamo il giocatore mi ami strano
perché
[Musica]
altri tutto è troppa ti prego quei
giocatori
oggi qualcosa mi dice che vincerò b2
minuto
[Musica]
e non ci credo non me la cavo probabile
con obiettivo futuro del giocatore
normale mi sa che mi piace di più fare
il cattivo
quanti personaggi anche allora io vedo
un giocatore due giocatori due giocatori
che ci credo ma sono bravi giocatori
come trappole magari
dove siete allora dove si è uscita fuori
fatevi eliminare d'amico pd c'è qualcuno
lì c'è un giocatore bloccato da qualche
parte devo rimanere questo giocatore
stranissimo quello bianco voglio che vi
fuori dal piano di sotto nella
lavanderia arrivo subito eliminarlo
metti sono tutte e due la software
realtà mettete le trappole
non c'è nessuna dell amba stavo di
averli visti di
far bruciare capitale
eccoli e là sopra presto mandiamo
prenderlo dove
qualcuno ha preso una trappola
no non ci credo è riuscita a scappare lo
stranoto ce la farò
tutto dentro non potere più che mai a
scafati e scappate scappate driver
si stanno nascondendo no non ci penso
ne ho fatto uno mancano el'altro tutto
strano che però è fortissimo con il
giocatore
da prendere è bravissimo sta scappando
sta scendendo forse lo faccio perché
conoscendo le che cela vitaly rus
76 trappola
promesso metto una trappola stato
bloccato da ognuno
porta una volta è riuscito a sbloccarsi
c'è qualcuno che dice vitale alla tua
skin è quella di vita mi piace molto
ma
ne mancano solo sbloccarsi così
rapidamente lo so cosa sta prendendo
l'ultimo grand aggio problema minore non
vinceremo l'ultimo ingranaggio nell
ingranaggio rosso volevo dire di si
riesce a vincere comunque lo so se
riesci a vincere però io ne avevo messo
uno ha sbloccato tutto lì reto non si
crea ortissima questo giocatore
all'entrata allora aspetto
lucido
vincere non è riuscito a scappare
posso più fare allora sei stato molto
bravo
ok guardato eliminato tutti tranne quei
giocatori lì che approvi tv e super
esperto allora foresta foresta by
foresta no ma perché l'ultima cadute la
calma
è quella che fanno di più e magari
conoscono tutti i segreti siriani
è sì lo so quando vuoi vincere amici
pagine che si stia un orientati da
tutti giocatore alla casacca siamo pari
3 a 3 ma
magari infettati riesce a vincere siamo
tutto vediamo
infestati
che farà un caos vedrà partito
ecco allora dobbiamo far scappare la
perizia un club così per clancy se si
prende pd pupazzo greco i gialloblù
diventiamo anche noi pighi pupazzo grace
e poi ha certo punto diventano tutti i
pedi pupazzo brain ed è molto difficile
ora voglio vedere un ottimo giocatore ma
anche bravissimo riusciva a vincere
anche questa partita super difficile 5
sta per arrivare g direi pighi graham i
grandi musical
bracalini è bellissimo non ho eliminato
qualcuno quindi abbiamo due grigi adesso
paura
ce ne sono 20 piu persone prendono piu
difficile sara doveva la porta
e 187 no non mi piace abbiamo preso che
a me veramente mi dispiace un coraggioso
lui ero anch'io sono anche le
va bene c'è un pupazzo blu che carino
meno male siamo un po diversi ormoni uno
non ha preso il tuo bacio blu e ora
siamo tutti chi sono chiudersi
senza super prova super bravo no l'hanno
treno dice miur a quanti siamo
siamo tutti dei abbiamo vinto
volete che continuiamo a giocare a
puppet magari problemi tutte le altre
modalità l'ha fatto bene ora vi lasciamo
stare a sentire su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri due squadre ferite
[Musica]